spirituality as a whole program must
also self-destruct
for you to return to the natural state
[Music]
that's right it's a good segue into
jumping into the stages
that is as frank just described to you
in these short stages that is this
fifth stage transcending the entire
paradigm of spirituality itself that
very
natty state the natural state
so we'll go ahead and pull up towards
this
long definition of the stages
first and a brief entry
into that we're just going to mention
that each stage has three
levels there's the more intellectual
there's the experiential and the
realized and it's important to be
sincere and honest with which
level you are at with each stage
let's go ahead and have frank kick us
off with
the stages defined long
okay let's do it so um
before i go into the stages i just want
to remind people that all the stages are
just references just like the code that
i read
nothing can no labels can't touch
this but during the path it's very
valuable to have stages
i mean it helped myself and a lot of
other people and if you look at a lot of
different research
about the different stages of wicking
that actually people go through like
worship jeffrey martin
or even the theravada four path model
whether
the models that are you know uh
advocated by people like daniel ingram
or whatever tradition that you're in
there's always going to be some kind of
stages in there
except for the really radical non-dual
teachers but usually people do go
through different stages among
and the stage we're going to talk about
if you really want to match it you can
match it to
any school any tradition and it would
make sense
stage number one is ego state stage of
separation basically you're identifying
yourself
with this character inside the mitsu
your sense of identity your sense of
self
is behind the eyes inside the head
or somewhere in the midsum you're a
contracted
you're separated from the rest of the
environment there's a huge
gap between the subject and the object
okay second stage you have the awareness
and consciousness phase
this is where i would say 95 of
mainstream spiritual teachers
talk about they tell you to abide in
awareness
they tell you that your true self is
awareness or abide in consciousness or
witness observer whatever
the reason for that is because after you
see through that the ego is an illusion
that is just a fabrication
you have to move your sense of identity
to a larger ground after you have more
spiritual openings and glimpses
and then you sort of disidentify from
the ego and now your identification is
with this new ground of awareness and
consciousness
now this is a very vast infinite
spacious field
almost but there's still an observer
here
there's still someone that's observing
the ego
and the next step is to unplug even that
to dissolve
even the observer to be aware of
awareness
to witness the witness observe the
observer
and if you can't witness anything or
observe anything you can still
disidentify from it you can still
objectify it
and you realize that the observer is
just actually more solidify sensations
in the field of experience that's taking
credit for
nature or the universe at first it was
the ego taking credit for it you have
this huge
block of solidity like a marble taking
credit trying to take credit
or liquidity and then
awareness trying to take credit for
infinity
so now your new identification is
awareness and the reason
people ask you to abide awareness it's
not this is a very important point it's
not to create a new identity out of
awareness and be like
i am awareness i mean that is a better
more spacious identity than the ego but
it's still an identity
after you unplugged your awareness you
dissolve even the observer
you move it to the third stages which is
what i call the god stage
uh this is the infinity stage you know
the creator
being christ consciousness ottoman
big self true self love existence
the universal mind and this third stage
is what i call the pinnacle of
spirituality
the pinnacle of spiritual experiences
anyway maybe not the thing of
spirituality but the pinnacle of human
especially experiences
and a lot of people think this is it
which it could be i mean every stage is
completely of itself don't get me wrong
every single stage every aspect of the
jewel the multiplicity of jewel of
enlightenment is complete
so we're not really making a hierarchy
it's more like
horizontal
anyway at the the third stage we
identify with the godhead
with the universal mind but there is
still a very subtle
very subtle identification because even
at this point at this stage
the separation hasn't been completely
dissolved so you feel like you're
merging with the divine
as long as there's merging there's still
very subtle sense of duality
so that's why i want to make a very
clear distinction between
you as a separate person experiencing
the divine versus just the divine
recognizing itself
universe [ __ ] itself versus you
trying to [ __ ] the universe
there is a big distinction there anyway
so after the third stage we move on to
nothingness
after expansion what do we get we did
contraction this whole process is about
expansion and contraction
after you expand to infinity you shrink
down from the big bang to the big crunch
down to the singularity of
nothingness emptiness nirvana numbing
or brahman death non-existence
basically three and four are two sides
of the same coin
so at this phase um you have this very
nebulous sense of self total loss of
identity
where the third stage you go around
saying hey i am god
and the second say yo hey bro i'm
consciousness don't you get it
i've gone through spirituality i am
consciousness and thursday's
you i sub consciousness no i'm god
and the fourth stage is dude no i didn't
i don't even know what i know anymore
total loss of identity you have this
really vague anabolic sense of self that
you can't define at all
and this is kind of like the stuff that
buddha talks about
the emptiness the originations
where you disidentify
from even god consciousness because if
you can be aware of
god consciousness if you can experience
god consciousness
it's still an object within your field
of experience that you can
still disidentify and objectify and make
it not self and not this not that
so we're doing something korean along
the way right
um and after this phase you slip into
the natural state now this is very very
tricky
because stage three and four a lot of
people would
get stuck in a stage thinking this is it
which again i completely understand
because i've been there
and again each stage is complete but
there's more to the picture there's more
to the faster different
jewels of enlightenment the nothingness
face
um if you can still experience this very
subtle sense of
lost sense of self so to speak there's
still an experience there
if there is an experience you can still
witness it and objectify from it
and after you disidentify
and disembed all the previous stages
spontaneously you move to this
fifth stage what i call true no self or
the natural state the towel
so this stage not only transcend all the
other stages
includes them as well because the only
way to truly embody something
is to this identify from it if you let
go of it it becomes yours
even more fully and all the previous
stages all the experiences all the
mind-blowing exhibitions you had
that can be experienced even more fully
paradoxically without the experiencer in
the middle
and this is the whole process is to
dissolve the center point
if you want to boil this down to the
i guess the microscopic level it's all
about dissolving sensations
and the last piece of sensation to get
dissolved from solidity to emptiness
is usually somewhere in the center in
the head before it was in the body
but then you keep shedding [ __ ] and
shedding and it was in the head
and even if this last little bit of
speck of sensation is as tiny as an atom
it's still going to project itself onto
a new ground and the smaller this atom
is
the bigger this ground is and to get to
a natural state you have to dissolve not
just the
ego but the background as well
the background that gets created from
the separated state
and say oh even though my identity is
this tiny little thing here that i can't
even find
in the middle of my experience that's
still gonna kind of
hang on to some sort of a ground some
sort of source like brahman or like
godhead
and very subtly you're still going to
think hey i am from
i am god this is just a godhead this is
my idea shantae
um let that uh learn not only
we'll get to other channel later but
this is what i said if realizing true
self
of no self is like perceiving the world
without the eyeball
because the eyeball can't see itself but
you can see everything else
so if you really truly recognize no self
you're not going to be able to
experience or even sleep in those songs
if you still have this sense of oh i'm
looking for the self but i can't find it
oh it's infinite that's still not true
no self there's true no self there's
nothing you can say about it
but the eyeball that nothing could be
said about can see things
and the manifestation of this what it
sees
you can describe and there's infinite uh
levels to the manifestation
um if that's
finding out your true self an eyeball
that can't see itself another analogy
that's similar is
a mirror versus no mirror
first you have a source you perceive the
world as
phenomenon rising and passing out of a
mirror the mirror could be any ground
that you encounter in the past
with the consciousness or awareness or
the god mind
but after you truly dissolve separation
if the ego is gone so is the so is the
mirror so it's a sword so is the ground
so you have to deconstruct even the
background
you have to do self-increase with the
self the small self the ego
and then you have to self-include the
big self you have to do something
with the god mind but to do that you
first have to access the god mind
you have to access and identify with
something before you keep this
identified from it
so always that's why all these different
paths have to be
sort of go through you go through each
one of them and then you just identify
for them
but by dissatisfied form you actually
disappear into them if you disappear
into them you actually manifest them
even more forward
so they're only reflections but no
mirror at the end
there's only a manifestation there's no
unmanifested
there's no source no background the
unmanifested is just something that you
imagine
because how can there be something
that's not manifested if it's
non-duality
if this is one thing right there's only
the manifesto
there's no mirror that's the answer to
the
zen colon what is the sound of one hand
clapping
that's that that's the answer to that
quran
they actually called there's actually
this damn master or maybe
i think he was reading some uh some poem
or something student wrote
and first student was writing about oh
man the mind is like a mirror i have to
shine in the mirror
and everything is just coming in and out
this buddha my this natural mind
but then after that he realizes wait a
second this mirror this buddha might
also just a construction and then he
said there's no mirror
that [ __ ] up
okay that was a little thank you
there we go thank you a little
presentation
all right before before we go i just
want to say one more thing if you find
the stage
the stage is very complicated just
remember one thing this whole spiritual
path is about one thing
this solution of the conditions that
makes up the separate self
the more you dissolve the more glimpses
of reality which is formless it's opened
up
and all those mystical experiences that
you experience are just a byproduct of
this realization itself is not an
experience
and the separate self both disappear
without the subject
there won't be an object even the object
that is god consciousness
eventually dissolves and there's just
this
the absolute normie
now you're free to put on different
lenses of perception
as you see fit yeah so basically the
entire spiritual path if you find
this whole map too complex just remember
that the whole process
is the solution of the separate self in
this condition that's it
the more you dissolve the bigger opening
you're gonna get
that's why the stages of awareness and
god and nothingness whatever right
um so if the separation is completely
dissolved
when the subject in the center is
completely bandaged so is the background
the background is also going to vanish
so it's not like there's really
ultimately no difference between ego
awareness infinity and it's all the same
they're just different reconfiguration
and solidity of sensations which we're
going to talk about in a bit what
sensations
are but perfect